[Music]
you've been carjacked right don't turn
around this won't take
long wait who are you someone who
prefers not getting
involved you refer to the special
investigators as your team your soldiers
even your friends you do not mess with
the special
investigator and now they're all in
[Music]
trouble they were tortured they dumped
them from a helicopter and they're
coming after
us
[Music]
good damn Reacher we were kids we just
wrote our names in it why'd you got to
hit him so
high I don't hit
soft what are our
directors we prepared we investigate we
put B guys in jail what does he think
he's going to
do just like the good old days yeah you
on the sidelines while I do all the
work he's a boss and bosses give
orders but they took a run at us in
Broad day like
they getting
desperate guys got good instincts guys
got good
everything surveillance photos don't do
you
justice looks like you had a rough night
had
worse need a new jacket what's wrong
with the one you just bought it has
blood on
it